[Musique]
combien de manille faire donne du lait
pour la consommation humaine ici au
canada trois mammifères produisent du
lait destiné aux humains
la vache la chair et la brebis une vache
toutes races confondues produit en
moyenne neuf mille deux cents litres de
lait par année
la chèvre près de six ans c'est beaucoup
moins 90% du lait de chèvre est destiné
à la fabrication de fromages
le reste est vendu sous forme de y ou
bourg de beurre ou tout simplement de
lait le lait de chèvre occupe une très
petite part de marché - 2 % de
l'ensemble du lait de consommation
vendus au québec et au canada
quant à la brebis elle donne 270 litres
de lait en moyenne par année
senna est principalement transformé en
fromage mais à travers le monde
d'autres mammifères sont utilisés pour
la production laitière
la jument la nes la chamelle la
bufflonne mais aussi les femelles du
lama du yak et dure elle en 2017 la
production mondiale donnait atteignait
près de 800 milliards de litres elle
était dominée par le lait de vache 83%
de bufflonne celui de chèvre et de
brebis compléter l'offre
selon une récente étude la production
mondiale de lait devraient augmenter de
22 % d'ici 2026 et aux principales sont
prévues au pakistan et en heure